bonsoir et bien nous sommes à aubigny
une petite ville devant des 2000
habitants mais pas n'importe quel
habitant vous allez le voir je suis
assis sur une chaise qui apparemment est
tout à fait normal mais cette chaise
elle est sur le plateau de la plus
grande chasse du monde 12 mètres 10 de
hauteur et c'est l'oeuvre d'un artisan
d'aubigny c'est un des trente record que
pendant tout un week end la population
de cette petite ville va tenter de
battre des records qui seront d'ailleurs
homologué dans le livre guinness des
records outre cette chaise un autre
record fabuleux un puzzle un puzzle
géant cent vingt mille pièces 31 mètres
de long 9 mètres de haut il représente
le manège enchanté de serge danot et
pour faire un peu pareil il fallait
vraiment être aussi
je suis persuadé qu'ils sont fous mais
c'est une folie tellement agréable étant
donné que ils font les choses
sensationnelles et je trouve que c'est
la plus belle folie qui puisse exister
c'est de réaliser des réaliser les rêves
qu'est ce qui les pousse à faire un
festival comme celui ci au festival de
records je connais bien pour la raison
suivante et je suis vendéen de 200 et
vendéen de coeur et
on a toujours un peu le complexe du
vendéen et on veut faire voir que nous
aussi on est capable de faire tard les
genoux sans avoir besoin de faire des
choses assez désagréable pour tout le
monde c'est beaucoup plus facile à faire
mais nous on avait entrepris de faire
des choses énormes c'est à dire des dés
par exemple année un énorme panier qui
est de la tradition locale une énorme
jarre tout ça ce sont des choses que nos
ancêtres ont fait on a voulu faire voir
aux gens que vous pouvez toujours le
faire et en très grand
[Musique]
tout un très grand même en trop grand
comme pour ce jeu de patience ou des
dizaines d' équipes ont dû se relayer
nuit et jour pour coller et pour clouer
les pièces
et puis sous un soleil de plomb qui on
fera souffrir plus d'un à commencer par
les sportifs comme claude guinard 48 ans
qui va tenter le record d'endurance à
vélo record détenu par pierre de bruyne
avec 48 heures sans quitter la scène
à la gare hadja ce week-end aura déjà un
sri lankais va s'attaquer à son propre
record lever la jambe plus de 9100 fois
et il va souffrir
plus de deux heures avec un sac de blé
de 80 kg sur les épaules s'en sortir
d'un socle d'un mètre carré bon courage
r&d poiron
dur aussi de construire un mur en
parpaings le plus vite possible
le record à battre est d'une heure pour
un mur de 15 mètres de long et de 2
mètres 42e aux 240 papin imposé et droit
[Musique]
il faut le faire vite très vite encore
plus vite
[Musique]
cinquante minutes 43 secondes record du
monde battu de quoi être fier et voilà
aussi qui mérite une bise de christine
gilles miss guinness qui homologue ici
les records du monde
[Musique]
oui c'est le plus grand râteau du monde
12 mètres 55 de long 1 m 70 de large ils
se sont mis à trois pour le construire
mais pour cette horloge comtoise ils
étaient plus de trois pour allumer les
allumettes souffler dessus et les coller
un geste répété 270 mille fois l horloge
marche
nouvelle épreuve inscrite dans ce
festival est donc un record à établir le
lancer de crêpes sans oublier bien sûr
de la faire cuire avant de la faire
sauter
[Applaudissements]
ici le record à battre est de 97 m il
consiste à lancer un oeuf cru et à le
rattraper sans casser évidemment
[Musique]
records n'ont battu et pendant ce temps
là les hommes forts eux souffrent claude
guinard peine sur son vélo déjà plus de
30 heures qu'il est en scène
notre étudiant sri lankais a déjà levé
la jambe plus de six mille fois mais il
est encore loin de son record
et personne n'a voulu imiter hervé
poiron il porte son sac sous le soleil
depuis plus d'une heure
avec l'équipe de football d'aubigny un
autre record tombe celui du raid ballon
au pied attrait ils ont parcouru 120 km
avec le plus jeune record man 9 ans et
sur la fête la doyenne 81 ans elle
s'attaque aussi un record du monde mais
pour le battre ce record il faut d'abord
attraper un mouton puis le tondre carder
la laine la filale à tisser et enfin
coudre un ensemble pour dames le record
tient depuis 1931 il est détenu par les
australiens qui ont réalisé toutes ses
opérations en 1h31
[Musique]
à aubigny toutes celles qui savent
encore se servir d'un roux et se sont
mobilisés et elles ont essayé d'aller le
plus vite possible et pour l'occasion on
a ressorti les vieux métiers les
machines affilée et on travaille à la
main à l'ancienne
[Musique]
seule la machine à coudre n'est pas
d'époque mais c'est vrai qu'en 1931 il y
avait déjà des machines à coudre
[Musique]
résultats de l'équipe ce bel ensemble
réalisé en 1h27 records du monde battus
et au passage un record pour bernard du
belge qui a comme but le mouton en une
minute et quinze secondes sans faux
scoop
là où également on s'active record de
vitesse en planeur sur le kilomètre
lancé 217 km heure le pilote à 17 ans
al'inverse record de lenteur pour lui
elle aime 40,22 km/heure à la limite du
décrochage
est à moitié dans les airs mais les
pieds sur terre le record de give her
très cher en équilibre sur le menton
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fin du calvaire pour notre ami sri
lankais et record de french cancan battu
il a levé la jambe dit 1376 fois en six
heures 5 minutes et 55 secondes
plus calme mais tout aussi
extraordinaire le record battu par une
douzaine d'auby noah ils ont tressé la
plus longue corde du monde 2 km 130 sens
ne s'en épissures
c'est une corde en sisal monté par
élément de 160 m ils ont entièrement
fabriqué le matériel à tresser mais ils
ne vous diront pas comment ils ont fait
pour éviter les noeuds les épis sur ça
c'est leur secret le précédent record
était détenu par les anglais depuis 1874
avec une corde d'un kilomètre 8 cents
seulement
[Musique]
le puzzle lui est pratiquement monte
toujours 31 mètres de long 9 mètres de
haut et 120 mille pièces ses 120 mille
pièces seront vendues au profit de la
lutte contre le cancer un travail de
titan qui pulvérise l'ancien record
établi par les américains en 1933 de
mettre 60 sur 4 mètres cinquante mille
pièces seulement ce puzzle avaient été
vendus au cirque barnum
maintenant le record le plus court
regardez bien lu durant une seconde
en une seconde remy bricka à jouer de
douze instruments guitare grosse caisse
caisse claire cymbales grelots clochette
tambourin qu'auront harmonica flûte
méritons et sirènes
[Musique]
gigantisme gigantisme sibot front réunis
sous un seul jour le plus grand joue du
monde évidemment
quatre mètres 30 de large il a fallu
trois mois au pis que pour dresser les
bleus et leur apprend à marcher sous se
joue mais il pourrait tirer sans peine
la charrue de gargantua qui a ici sa
chaise son panier en osier tressé son
yaourt 270 kg sa cuillère à yaourts 20
litres
ça jara grain deux mètres cinquante de
haut
et aussi sa nappe au crochet 25 mètres
cinquante de long elle a été réalisée
par le club du 3e âge d'aubigny encore
un record du monde
il
[Applaudissements]
record du monde au lancer très petit
mètre cinquante bravo monsieur david
[Applaudissements]
les potiers aussi était de la fête leur
concours réalisé la plus haute pompa
lessiveuse avec 8 kg de terre dans le
temps le plus court record pour francis
guillon 80 cm en 18 minutes et pour le
plaisir la plus grande jarres en terre à
m 55 réalisé par habib al fath dans la
tradition tunisienne
fin de l'épreuve pour hervé poiron cet
agriculteur d'aubigny est resté deux
heures 13 minutes et 44 secondes sous
son sac de 80 kg
[Musique]
fin du calvaire aussi pour claude
guinard il est resté quarante 9h15 sur
son vélo et a parcouru 1000 60 km mais
au bout de l'épreuve un très très beau
record du monde
ne s'agit pas ce que c'est effectivement
je leur ferai mais maintenant que je
sais ce que c'est
passé déjà plusieurs fois des nuits sur
le vélo mais leur art comme ça
franchement
deux records pour rené carpentier
l'homme du puzzle celui de la surface
est celui du nombre de pièces record de
nuits blanches aussi mais sûrement pas
record de l'inutile puisqu'au bout il y
a le plaisir et la fierté
[Musique]
oh
oui
on
mais
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
à
c
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
et
mais bon
il
dernier record pour jean marc barbeau
président du festival et pour la ville
de bobigny record bien sûr de la ville
du monde qui détient le plus grand
nombre de records et de celles qui ont
abattu le plus en un week end il fallait
le faire
ça vous fait quoi
[Musique]